and while biden turns national security
against american citizens
he's let the border become a national
security nightmare this month alone
cbp is on track to take in a record 16
000 migrant use and they're all in
custody but have no fear because today
biden announced
he was foisting this job onto vice
president
kamala harris now the same person who in
a fit of political expediency
said something a little disturbing a few
years ago
we would not put children in cages the
human rights abuse being committed by
the united states government
we are not going to allow this to happen
not on our watch
i saw children lined up single file
based on gender
being walked into barracks these
children have not thank you senator
harris
and should be not treated like she's
criticizing her own administration back
then joining me now newt gingrich former
house speaker
fox news contributor newt um is that
kind of the kiss of death giving
the vice president the job of fixing the
border when
given her past comments about the way
the border was enforced
well first of all it's very clever of
biden on the eve of his press conference
to turn it over to her so every question
tomorrow about the border he can say you
know
that's vice president harris's job you
need to talk to her about it
next question uh in that sense he
managed us to duck
all responsibility for what is not a
crisis it's a disaster
and it's getting worse 92 percent of
hispanic americans
want every person who comes into this
country
tested for covet 90 overall of all
americans
want them tested for covet there's no
possibility
that this administration will do that
and i think what will happen is
vice president harris who's a very good
politician
will presently explain how wonderful
things are
how really cool they are know we're not
going to let the news media go down
but trust me it's okay and she'll go on
to something else
i think that you know her future is not
dependent
on what happens on the border her future
is dependent
on what happens in the white house uh
with with president biden
hey newt breaking late tonight the
pentagon
announced that they're approving an hhs
request to temporarily house
unaccompanied migrant children at vacant
dormitories at
joint base san antonio in lachlan texas
and providing an area of land in fort
bliss
to construct a suitable temporary
housing facility newt why the heck is
our military getting involved in this we
have a lot of homeless people living
under
intense in dc tonight
if you're if you're not going to build
the wall
you're going to build a heck of a lot of
dormitories that's a very simple
equation
they are presently going to drown in
people who come north
and every time there's a tv story about
this more people come north
and they're not all from central america
we're finding people from africa
from china from india from turkey
there's a continuing wave coming to the
u.s this is essentially
a peaceful invasion by a huge number of
people
uh by this summer it may well be over a
million people
the the biden administration won't be
able to handle it
this whole thing is just going to fall
apart but what they will do is what
they've been doing all along
they'll just lie newt are we to believe
that this is not going to affect
uh the poorest americans the most
this influx of of mostly
poor and uh obviously
non-english-speaking
migrants into the united states
well first of all and this is why
support for testing
for covet is higher among hispanics than
among all americans
the first people going to be affected
are relatively poor people who are going
to have
infected people who have not been tested
have not been tracked
do not have medical help showing up in
their neighborhoods
we go through all of these things at the
airport we go through all these tests at
the airport
and then we have a policy under biden
that allows people to come in here
second you're exactly right uh the
poorest americans
will have their wages suppressed by this
competition and third
every taxpayer is going to get hit we're
going to provide
we're going to provide shelter food
we're going to provide
education then we're going to provide
health care uh we're taking on here
billions and billions of dollars of
additional cost
and 42 million apparently want to come
that's the latest gallup survey on how
many people want to come to the united
states i guess we're not so systemically
racist after all
newt thank you great to see you